على مدى اربع بطولات من المونديال وخلال
اثنا عشر عاما دخلت الحيوانات في اطار
التسليه والحماسه الموندياليه عبر
استخدامها بتوقع نتائج مباريات اصابت هذه
الحيوانات في مرات واخطات في اخرى الباندا
الحالي هو الاقل دقه على ما يبدو لكن في
هذا المونديال تحديدا يدخل الذكاء
الاصطناعي بقوه في التوقعات مع استمرار
مباريات المونديال الحالي يتوقع كمبيوتر
عملاقه هويه الفائز في نهائيات كاس العالم
الكمبيوتر تتوقع فوز فرنسا بالمونديال
الحالي لكن بنسبه تقارب ال18%
منذ مونديال 2010 استخدمت العديد من
الحيوانات في التوقعات الخاصه بنتائج
مباريات البطوله العالميه اولها الاخطبوط
بول شغل العالم في كاس العالم 2010 في
جنوب افريقيا بعد تحقيقه لعدد جيد من
التوقعات الصحيحه ومنها توقعه فوز اسبانيا
بكاس العالم ايضا
الصيني كان في مركز للحفاظ على الحيوانات
الباندا في الصين وتوقع العديد من نتائج
مونديال 2014 في البرازيل لاسيما المباراه
الافتتاحيه التي تغلبت فيها البرازيل على
كرواتيا ايضا من العرافين القطه اخيل وكان
قططا اصاما وظهر في روسيا خلال مونديال
2018 كان ناجحا في عده توقعات ومنها توقعه
نتيجه مباراه مصر وروسيا في دور المجموعات
في قطر الان اثنين من دببه الباندا سهيل
توقعان نتائج المونديال وفشلاف الكثير
منها اهمها توقعهم لخساره السعوديه من
الارجنتين حيث حدث يومها عكس ما توقع
الحيوانات العرافان
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
من الرياض ينضم الينا المؤثر في التقنيه
وصانع المحتوى فيصل سيف يسعد صباحك دائما
يا فيصل تحيه موندياليه اليوم
فوز اكيد المنتخب المغربي جدا جميل الله
يبارك الجميع فيصل اليوم كمبيوتر خارق ضرب
توقعات كل الحيوانات
والتحليلات الرقميه يخرج بنتائج مباريات
المونديال من الناحيه التقنيه كيف يمكن
تفسير ذلك
طيب من ناحيه 28 لازم اذكر اني شخصيه
متابعه على كل شيء له علاقه
لما نيجي على التقنيه نفسها وكيف انها
تقدر فعليا من الخوارزميات وايضا من
النتائج وقواعد البيانات الكثيره اللي
موجوده موجوده من مباريات سابقه تشمل نفس
الفريقين وموجوده ايضا من المباريات سابقه
للفريقين مع منتخبات اخرى فبالتالي قدرات
والقوه اللي موجوده مع كل لاعب واللي تم
رصدها من خلال الحساسات المستشفرات
والاداءات الماضيه تلعب دور جدا مهم
فالايام تدخل فيها خوارزميات الجو تدخل
فيها ايضا الملعب هل هو ملعب مستطيل مغترب
من ملعب محلي انه مرضى كلها تدخل فيها
فبالتالي الفرص حقك نقدر نقول التوقعات
يظل مبنيه على بيانات وليست مبنيه على
متجر ونقول فقط
دائما غير متوقعه في الساحره الخضراء
المستطيله يعني ارهاق اجهاد نفسي ضغ نفسيه
وحتى اصابات غير متوقعه تكون حتى لكبار
اللاعبين والمحترفين في هذه الحاله الا
اما توقعات الكمبيوتر الخارق تكون نسبيه
مهما ذكر الكمبيوتر نسبه التوقعات ورده
وارتفعت هذه النسبه هي ظل كون الامر مرتبط
بالبشر في عام البشر العامل البشري هو
النقطه الاكبر في احداث اي تغيير وفي عامل
اكثر من كده اكيد تفضل الالهيه سبحان رب
العالمين
ايش اللي يصير نتيجه وبالتالي لو رجعنا
على امر نستخدم فيه التوقعات لعشرات السنه
الثانيه المملكه العربيه السعوديه والعالم
كله وصل الى منتج عالي في الخوارزميات مع
قواعد بيانات تمتد احيانا الى 100 سنه
بتكلم على توقعاتنا هذا الجويه وفعليا
توقعات الاحوال الجويه تتم من خلال بيانات
الخوارزميات نسبه التوقعات انها نقدر نقول
تحدث عاليه جدا ليش لوجود قواعد اكبر بنفس
الخوارزميات والبيانات اللي موجوده سابقا
صارت معنا تهيؤات الجو
العوامل اللي موجوده كلها
ولكن لما نجيء لانه مباريات عندنا القواعد
الضخمه بالجامعه ما بين المنتخب الاسباني
والمنتخب المغربي على سبيل المثال عشرات
المرات
كان جدا محذوف فبالتالي نسبه حدوث
التوقعات ايضا طيب فيصل في هذا المونديال
تحديدا في مونديال قطر شاهدنا يعني دخول
الذكاء الصناعي بقوه كره الرحله كره
استشعار كره ذكيه شاهدنا تقنيه التسلل شبه
الالي واليوم كمبيوتر خارق يتوقع نتائج
مباريات المنتخب
مين الذكاء الاصطناعي حيستمر في تواجد
بشكل جدا كبير ولولا احدنا هذا المونديال
مع القدر الكبير مع الذكاء الاصطناعي
والاهداف الملقاه ايضا التسللات المحسوبه
جعلت من المونديال بناء ضخم على صحه ودقه
المباراه واللاعب وعلى
تقليل اخطاء العنصر البشري فلاقينا نتائج
غير متوقعه تماما تماما في كثير من
المباريات في اهداف لو حسبت كان الامر
المعتاد بالفوز من فريق محدد هو اللي
هيصير ولكن بعض الاهداف عدم حسبانها
وجعلها في دائره التسلل في الدوائر الاخرى
لانها بالفعل نحصل على مونديال مبني على
الاداء النظيف 100% وليس على احيانا خطا
البشري من ناحيه التقييم التقدير او حتى
الاداء في اللعب هنا نعرف انه التقنيه
والذكاء الاصطناعي تستمر لانه اعطتنا روح
مختلف في هذا المونديال من مساله النتائج
مساله الابداع ما يجي هذا الا فعلا الناجي
انه يستحق هذا الامر وتقنيات كثيره تبنيت
وهذه التقنيات بالفعل عادت بشكل مره
ايجابي ولكن الدور نقد تجربه الفيفا لكل
الدوريات العملاقه اللي موجوده في العالم
ساعدنا دائما بوجودك معنا المؤثر في
التقنيه مصانع المحتوى فيصل سيف شكرا
جزيلا يا فيصل